bertrand préparer une émission within
moi je suis scandalisé 6 pas réalisé bah
je vais vous dire laissez moi terminer
seconde année organisé en mai balances
ton post c'est complètement plagié sur
touche pas à mon poste ça alors alors
non je vais vous dire un truc je vous
dire un truc tation ça et ils le savent
la production non c'est impossible de
faire balances ton post voilà donc c'est
pas moi je pense tous les postes où
cette époque c'est tellement pas mon
problème
même si elle est vrai que le ch et vous
voilà non même posté post7 son émission
sur la télé avec une bande c'est
exactement ça rejoint ce que vous avez
et puis je rappellerai simplement que
pour moi bertrand chapron a pour
répondre à votre question n'a pas
d'avenir en tant que l'une de ses bras
madame et rod fanni matin et que tous
ceux qui ont quitté ici comme
chroniqueur pour devenir animateur ça
n'a jamais marché
ben faites le vous voir nettement l'âge
il a parfaitement raison c'est une
blague
il appelle son émission balance mon
poste pour des chroniqueurs pour
laissera pas bien cible non mais même là
on sait jamais qui veut refaire tout
soit mon poste mais si vous dès qu on a
envoyé on aurait alors eu lui la
victoire et j'ai production qu'on
connaît bien
je vous le dis les gars vous faites pas
chier avec ça vous allez mettre faire
des logos tout ça qui monte au galop
donc passé un autre titre comme ça c'est
réglé non mais je vous dis la vérité et
moi en ce qui concerne les prochains
mois je pense qu'il a un grand avenir
même mémo siraga renforts arrivés les
retraités les fans ou pas non non nine
et jérôme renaud non pourquoi
pour savoir si vous en aviez parlé
ensemble panorama des bleus alors je
vais vous dire là on les a pas trop au
téléphone en ce moment voilà c'est pas
des gens j'ai très souvent des versets
way home et cellules qui rafla grand
avenir est en jeu c'est parce qu'il a du
talent mais en chef de bande il a déjà
prouvé que c'était pas trop son truc
arrive il est trop jeune et trop vert
s'est pas encore s'est il n'a pas
l'envergure pour être chef de bande
en revanche il devrait faire la comédie
du cinéma mais là c'est pas que tu
trembles hanouna puisque c'est pas une
petite augmentation qui est un beau
chèque de son côté on peut être très
bien faire les chroniqueurs c'est
bertrand chamerois des propositions
vous êtes vous retomber dans l'anonymat
tu m'as terminé en toi pour dire la
perte de 0 3 seconde
non je trouve que c'est un garçon qui a
beaucoup de talent 2 ouvre le bon moment
pour le moment chez moi qu'il est un
petit peu vers il manque un petit peu de
charisme pour animer une bande et tout
ça je pense que c'est un peu tôt et
attention à lui parce que s'ils
prenaient à trop un deuxième but on a
tendance à dire que la télévision deux
buts voire 3 bis d'après c'est terminé
je pense que c'est un petit peu tôt et
en de café rivés sur médias maintenant
tu as toutes les eaux se sont plantés
tout sur paris vont admirer tout ça tout
ce sont plus de noms lui avait proposé
aux covers possible alors là j'en ai
tiré aucune conclusion
j'aurais aimé qu'ils reviennent parce
que pour moi par tranche m maurat il a
quitté le nid et le père un peu trop tôt
pour moi il aurait dû grandir encore à
vos côtés pourquoi pas sur le groupe
canal et il est parti un peu
précipitamment dans les larmes ça c'est
pas très bien pas de sartre illhousiens
curie de la vérité de grands patrons
canal n'est pas hyper fan de bertrand
chamerois d'aujourd'hui dans la
direction de canal+ n'est pas hyper fan
de bertry fermeront vous dit voilà
autant camille on est très fan autant
bertrand chamerois amoureux j'essayais
de ramener d'autres fois ils trouvent
pas qui voit là il pour eux et ils n'y
croient pas voilà la vérité donc je
préfère vous dire la vérité il n'y croit
pas voilà après donc c'est sûr qu'il n'y
aura pas dans le groupe canal essayer de
le ramener matt et manfred montré que je
n'ai pas autant d'influencé
vous pouvez le croire benjamin forcer
beaucoup mais pas dû beaucoup insisté
deux minutes après un excellent
chroniqueur ne fait pas nécessairement
un bon animateur vous dîtes ça pour vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le nom de l'émission j'ai l'impression
que c'est un dernier sursis pour
bertrand chamerois qui a fait au fini
d'accord ça a été ballotté par la
programmation n'est après tout que c'est
un vrai pied de nez de sa part envers
vous on peut pas parler de catch up donc
on n'a pas vu le programme en tant que
tel mais les émissions médias les
auteurs en devenir qui est en train
d'être fou d'elle c'est pas terrible
mais par le mois dernier sur si vous
avez peu près le même âge non oui on est
alors messieurs alors l'agressé comme ça
oui alors mes bagues en sursis comme
d'avoir un vieillissement va dire moi en
tant que téléspectatrice à l'époque je
les trouvais beau il avait l'air
intelligent et je l'aimé bien à sa
chronique donc moi j'ai rien à lui
reprocher du tout et pourquoi pas à voir
avec un autre nom bien sûr donc bien sûr
c'est le nombre de dons sera pas
possible